a pris cela pour nouveau venu dans tpm
paix alors bas alors écoute sèche comme
je disais tout à l'heure c'est une
dernière aventure peut-être pour mais
n'en suis jamais posé de questions je
suis sûr qu'après tu feras chasse et
pêche ou un truc comme ça est-ce qu'il
faut que je peux te tutoyer il faut que
je te vois alors vous êtes patrice
laffont vous avez une carrière énorme
combien d'années de carrière plus de 40
ans donc vous pouvez m'appeler petit con
[Rires]
vous voyez où tutoyer mais faites comme
vous voulez patrice alors je te tutoie
est-ce que je peux de vannes et temps en
temps mais tu fais vous faites ce que
vous voulez moi que vous voyez et vous
vous allez maintenant admis je suis un
an à los rios gros patrice laffont vous
venez d'où non non à rhodes
non mais patrice laffont alors c'est une
nouvelle qui nous rejoint priscilla liot
merci d'avoir un petit peu ce que
précéder à fait je veux voir vraiment
toutes les photos de président est en
vacances et j'en fais une affaire
alors ça c'est priscilla sur un balcon
vous étiez ou cinq termes monsieur vous
étaient alignés dans le sas et priscilla
déguisé en anne roumanoff c'est bon vous
étiez moulin 5 065 car oui il ya
d'autres photos prime année l'unesco
il ya d'autres photos prises en malaisie
on dirait britney fait le tour du monde
alors pris sida vous êtes animatrice oui
vous travaille également avec massimo
ghini je crois sur radio vl exact est la
seule radio qui fait beaucoup d'antennes
et qui ne payent pas à l'horizon les ans
et moi je suis assez heureux de l'avoir
on va poser la question se pose ouais
ouais
sinon elle est tout seul c'était
important parce que vous à condition
qu'elle a accordée par ces mots oui je
suis célibataire
[Applaudissements]
ah oui mais oui mais à mon avis vous
allez rester longtemps voire tout à
l'heure je ne sais pas ce qu'il a fait
il a comme un tapis de sol et non lieu
on est à deux doigts de mes toiles comme
ici c'est magique
garda soir non mais franchement j'allais
devenir beau gosse il faut lui laisser
de trois ans ne vous inquiétez pas vous
vous étiez ou alors cet été au même
endroit que les années précédentes
non vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure et je
savais que radio cocotier si j'ose dire
ça marche parce que j'ai devant vous
étiez où est ce que tu as déjà nous
rejoindre la traditionnelle plage
d'autres savoie entre le lac léman et la
montagne qui s'appelle confiant quand
vous étiez encore amphion est toujours à
en firent leur sortie trop du cul du
monde où il ya un clan à younes met
alors invraisemblable moi qui n'ai pas
sur les réseaux sociaux
j'ai tout appris sur vous par radio
plages ses formes que vous étiez cassé
le poignet que vous jouiez quand même au
tennis que vous avez rencontrées qu'à
madame ce que vous avez sur une route
n'avait rien appris
et maintenant alors les gens ne veut pas
de vous mais à un moment j'ai trouvé une
tactique pour pas être prise en selle
filles et donc pour rentrer dans la ddt
dans l'eau en rampant ah oui et alors la
technique est très très envie de la
faire un bain vous dites vous montre ben
oui c'est quoi chez vous il est en
direct il est 18h26 et ce sera la
première séquence tristesse moment cette
saison il avait l'année
[Applaudissements]
alors la caméra hélas pas non pour
moitié de la non mais n'entend pas
partir de la rade à zalla dans son store
y arrive
non mais dans le tunnel sortir de là
j'arrive avec une serviette de plage de
façon tahitienne autour de la taille car
j'ai des abdos je vais jusqu'au bord de
l'eau comme ça au bord de l'eau je
m'agenouille je pose la serviette comme
ça et j'avance dans l'eau comme ça vous
allez je suis très déçu je sors paraît
hélas il ya toujours quelqu'un qui me
dit aux izards hanouna comment il va
gérer c'est vrai c'était génial
martelly n'a vraiment pas vous et je
suis d'un malaise
les patristique et comme si la belle oui
mais la prochaine fois from la nasa côté
tour a créé un petit coin et pas non
mais elle m'a dit tout à l'heure en loge
elle m'a dit je suis très contente et
très content qu'ils aient patrice
laffont c'est lui qui va pour attriste à
faux par rapport à moi c'est qu'elle va
dams mais moi je sers encore ce qui se
passe je sers encore offrir un bon jour
deux fois de savoir ça y est alors les
panna cotta tout ça c'est bon ça a été
cet été ahmed très bien merci mon amour
à salins votre mari oui toujours là
embrasse aussi toujours là pour nous
regarder on embrasse très fort alain que
j'aime beaucoup
kelly vélo vélib au soir bon ça comment
ça va trop bien aller bronzer celle ci
c'est ça alors
alors vous avez perdu vous avez perdu du
pot oui j'ai passé mon été à éliminer le
début j'ai beaucoup énormément effet
d'éliminer vous et avec vous tenez j'ai
éliminé la photo de ses incroyables
logement à huy a oui j'ai pas donner des
photos de kelly innovation cette année
je vois que des photos de prix c'est
hier qu'a lives et dvd en vacances les
autres j'aime bien mais c'est pour moi
mon délire alors ouais donc repos les
potes et là vous étiez sur un sur bateau
petit bateau ce qu'on peut voir le
bateau nos salles en vendée le bot
tournesol ont rendez vous avec l'apa les
tournesols
ce qui tient son nom c'est van gogh
qu'on embrasse je suis qui nous
regardent l'embrasement gobe qu'un coach
est un petit peu d'histoire à eux
comment vois tu le sais comment il s'est
coupé l'oreille s'est coupé l'oreille
lui-même est ici vous voyez que gaël a
pris de rasoir et ses compagnons il a
accrochées sur le tableau c'est laure et
s'il vous plaît ne faites pas de
peinture ainsi accroché sur la toile le
l'oreille oui mais bien sûr que si les
gars non non non ça c'est spock nice
[Rires]
vous êtes en forme pour cette année
super en forme elle allait à la lada
niva et vous avez un petit camarade
déjà que j'ai découvert en allant faire
l'émission d'anne roumanoff anne
roumanoff que j'embrasse et voilà je les
ai vus on s'est vus on s'est regardés on
sait j'ai demandé du temps pour moi pas
se mentir c'est bon on va pas se mentir
comment il va il est très content d'être
là c'est vrai ouais ils appellent un
cygne rt les 16 ans stagiaire troisième
il a 34 11.32 pointe de 32 ans et ben ça
fait 34 c'est pour moi c'est cadeau je
suis très heureux que ce soit avec nous
belges franchement on peut l'applaudir
il
[Applaudissements]